sponsored by step finance your
go to d5 portfolio manager
on solana luno if you're just getting into
bitcoin it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the leia highway
fan show as always that is powered by icon plus
capital and it is sponsored by blockfi so today
i am in miami i'm very excited we're here for the
bitcoin conference and i thought i would get in
some interviews from some very high profile people
in the space so joining me today is a man that
i don't think needs much introduction but it is
bitcoiner robert breedlove i'm honored that
i fit your category of high-profile people
i think so oh it's my absolute pleasure and you're
obviously the host of the what is money show
yes um we've been doing it for almost a
year and a half now and it's been quite
successful so i'm very very humbled by it
and consider myself very grateful and lucky
to be able to do what i love every day i
totally agree with you i totally understand that
um but i'm curious about your background before
bitcoin i know that you're a hedge fund guy
so talk to me about your background yeah so i
have a master's degree in accounting and finance
so straight out of school i was actually
in public accounting for a number of years
uh basically focusing on tax strategy for high
net worth people and investment partnerships
and businesses so i kind of saw the belly of the
beast so to speak in terms of how people navigate
tax law and exploit loopholes and preserve capital
and all of that um but quickly discovered that was
not the business for me it's funny now that
i speak out against statism and taxation but
i actually have a master's degree in
taxation which is a little bit weird
i then got into basically the entrepreneurial
path i was a cfo for a number of tech companies
uh early in mid-stage and then basically fell
into the bitcoin rabbit hole late 16 early 17
and that's when i got into the hedge fund business
so i originally started a multi-strategy crypto
asset fund so we're trading in and out of a lot
of positions a lot of coins and then over time
as i was writing my monthly investor updates and
just trying to get my head around bitcoin i kept
falling more and more into the bitcoin rabbit
hole so becoming much more focused on bitcoin
at the exclusion of everything else um finally in
2020 my i guess a lot of people had realizations
that year my realization was that i was spending
all my blood sweat and tears in this hedge fund
business trying to outperform bitcoin which
is the best performing asset in human history
uh when i could just pivot to like basically an
accumulation position like i did with my personal
wealth and then free up all my time so that's
basically what i did and then i had this idea
inspired by a lot of things but um partly by
jordan peterson you know he has a successful
podcast he talks about this technological
revolution that we're in with youtube
and podcasting that effectively the cost of
bandwidth has gone to zero so we can talk about
anything and distribute it to the world at almost
zero cost so i thought um i would kind of zig
while everyone else is zagging a lot of people if
you go on youtube or podcast there's a lot of just
surface level discussion occurring i thought i
would uh capitalize on the low cost of bandwidth
and just do deep dives on whatever topics i wanted
to and the main question i think in the bitcoin
rabbit hole is what is money right like if you you
need to answer that question for yourself not that
it has one final answer but it's got a lot to
understand the implications of bitcoin itself
and uh serendipitously at that time i was going
to start the show mr sailor dm'd me said he had
just bought a lot of bitcoin and he appreciated
my work so i invited him on to be my first guest
and the sailor series is now 17 episodes long and
that's been a big success so that really launched
the show and um yeah i spend all my time reading
writing and talking to the smartest people in the
world about big ideas so very happy about that
yeah i really enjoyed the um the sailor podcast
um i watched pretty much all of those those
series but you're always asking people what is
money and i think michael sailor has this really
um technical approach with it almost quite like a
physicist almost um but you're quite philosophical
when you speak about bitcoin would you regard
yourself as a philosophical person and what sort
of philosophy do you live by and how has that
philosophy impacted your life yeah i've naturally
always been predisposed to deeper conversations
never been much for small talk i'm also
i can be an overthinker too like before
when i was younger before i got into yoga
actually yoga and meditation really helped
me figure out how to not be an overthinker
how to balance that out i just found myself
intellectualizing about things all the
time thinking about things all the time
but i never considered myself to be a philosopher
per se but i guess the nature of philosophy is
first of all it means love of wisdom right philia
sophia but it really has to do with inquiring into
the fundamental nature of things so if you've ever
hung out with like a two or three year old kid
and they're just asking why this why that
why this why that that's literally the child
trying to establish their philosophical anchor
points to the world so they know how to move
through the world and i guess i just never stopped
asking why about things um and i i don't know i
don't know how to turn it off or whatever and
now i'm fine with philosopher as a label people
have given me that the only thing i don't like is
when they say self-proclaimed philosopher because
i think that's a bit a bit trite for somebody
to do that and i don't label myself as such
i do label myself however as a freedom
maximalist i think that just captures
my deepest beliefs um for myself and what i want
to give others as well i think there's a weird
thing about freedom and that when we maximize it
not only do we maximize our satisfaction in life
but we also create more wealth and more
satisfaction of human wants on a global scale
so we know that sort of in america we have this
western civilization tradition but in recent years
you know specifically with the introduction of
central banking and fiat over the past century
we've started to regress against that and
i think bitcoin is just um the purest form
we've ever had of of a an implementation of the
principles of western civilization like it is life
liberty and property incarnate in many ways so um
i'm just so happy that bitcoin exists right now
given how crazy the world is going and i'm just
thrilled to be a part of this mission to educate
but but i don't want to say like it's not me
educating people i actually consider what i do
learning out loud like i'm just i'm learning i'm
talking to people i want to talk to about topics
i want to talk about that i find interesting that
advance my knowledge and then i get to share that
dialogue with the world and people engage with
that you know they can sense when you're i guess
surfing the edge of your own understanding and
hopefully exchanging ideas with people that
produce insights that you could not do
broadcasting from a podium if that makes sense
yeah i mean these podcast situations you can
get into so much more detail um you know you
talk about what is money so with all those
conversations that you've had in your opinion
what is money is it a store of value
is it um is it a means of transacting
or is it a transfer of energy like sailor says
you would think for a guy that runs a show called
the what is money show i'd have some canned
response for this when i go on other shows but
i actually have a document with over 50 answers
to that question and i've been actually writing
on my sub stack i've been publishing uh basically
a series of answers to that question like money
is this money is that money is this i never know
which one to pick when someone asks me but today
the one that comes to mind first is that
money is quite simply a title to human time so
we many of us probably own stocks or have owned
stocks at some point all that represents is an
ownership claim on the capital of that company
ultimately like if you go all the way to the
bottom of the stock certificate and i think
you can view money in a similar way in that
instead of being a title to a specific company's
capital it's a title to the global capital
stock right money can be used to acquire anything
the marketplace can bear this is any product
any good service knowledge whatever it may be
and all of those things are themselves products
of human time there's nothing that doesn't
take human time to produce right like even
people want to talk about land or even land
takes hands to sale takes takes time to sell
so in that sense money is really the most
important form of property humans have and
the more we economize our efforts so the
deeper we subdivide labor this is called
like the economic division of labor basically the
more intensity of exchange we have and the longer
more roundabout our production processes are the
more capital we can produce per unit of human time
so money ends up just being a claim on that that
uh economic surplus we create through cooperation
and it's frankly just the most
important tool humans can wield
so that's that's a temporal aspect on money like
as you mentioned sailor has this whole energy
aspect on money which is also equally fascinating
and complementary in a lot of ways and um
yeah that's just one example of i never thought
of money that way before talking to sailor
and there's other like i talked to um oh his
name escapes me at the moment he's basically uh
he's an evolutionary biologist and he described
money as liquid fitness right like in a darwinian
sense so there's all these unique answers that
have come out of these conversations that just
keep enriching my viewpoint and giving me new
answers to write about on what is money and you
said that right now you're particularly happy that
bitcoin exists and you said that bitcoin really
encompasses what western society is supposed to
be freedom liberty and all of that so i'd like to
get into that why particularly right now are you
happy that bitcoin exists what is the problem for
you right now that bitcoin is solving well the
problem in the world is excessive overgrowth of
the state or government um you know when you get
into the libertarian rabbit hole you come to see
government as the only business let's say
non-criminal business that does that derives
its revenue from involuntary exchange every
other business it's voluntary right you go to
buy the car you're negotiating a price you reach a
point and you execute the transaction or you don't
buyer and seller always have a say so in
every trade and every business in the world
that's not the case with government we've
been stuck in this it's almost like a
technological problem i think pre-bitcoin
that we've been stuck with a situation of
how do we preserve the integrity of the
relationship between people and their stuff
owners and assets that relationship itself by
the way is property right how do we preserve that
relationship in a way so we have to outsource
the physical security right someone has to
you have a deed to your house so if someone
comes in and sleeps on your couch you can call
you know the cops or whatever
security force to remove that person
how do we preserve that relationship
between people and their stuff in a way
that the security provider that's securing that
relationship does not use their security measures
to abuse that relationship and so that's what
the state is like we've outsourced all of our
physical security to one monopoly on violence
effectively and then we just trust them to charge
us the right price we don't negotiate it's almost
unnegotiable yes for most people 99.99 of people
there is a certain echelon of if you're you
know a billionaire or you're a multinational
conglomerate you can actually negotiate
with nation states because you've developed
so much negotiating leverage but for the vast
vast majority of people it's just not the case
so and when you have that it's almost
a contradiction in terms in a way
because you basically have the state saying hey
pay me to preserve this relationship between
you and your stuff whatever amount
i tell you or i'll take your stuff
so that's been like our our best solution to the
problem of property up until this point and that
is by the way the exclusive purpose of government
we get into these weird like we think governments
are supposed to do these other things that
uh you know preserve the greater good or
um whatever but that's all nebulous and doesn't
make a lot of sense like the fundamental economic
purpose of government is property so we've had
this weird thing where we've always needed the
monopoly on violence to honor the property rights
well along comes bitcoin i guess before that
where we are today it's like that uh institution
that monopoly on violence is now preying on the
property rights of people heavily um and this
is important to know too fiat currency inflation
when they're printing money we could think about
that one order deep and we think that's a good
thing but what's actually happening is just a
transfer of wealth from the people that can't
print money to the people that can print money
that's that's all it does printing money doesn't
add any new productive factors to the economy so
it's purely a mechanism for wealth to transfer
or so differently property violation fiat currency
inflation is a violation of property rights
so what are we doing in the post-covered world
we're rampantly violating when i say we the state
is rampantly violating the property rights of
citizens worldwide every central bank worldwide is
printing money to save the economy to help people
out and people believe it because they don't
understand money so bitcoin is important because
finally citizens have an option to preserve their
wealth in a medium or form of property that lives
independent of the monopoly on violence you just
basically the miners are providing the security in
the case of bitcoin um at a fair price right they
can't coerce you to use bitcoin they can't uh all
of the transaction fees are done in a free market
manner there's not there's not a course of element
within bitcoin so that gives citizens that may be
being preyed upon or oppressed by the state
in terms of having their property violated
an alternative an opt-out and so just by giving
people that option to exit i think in the long
run it actually forces government to behave more
honestly to actually treat people like customers
rather than subjects and so that's what
i'm trying to educate people about like
property is the sole purpose of government
property is also the basis of civilization
like ayn rand said if you can't if a man cannot
control the fruit of his own labor there he has
no other rights all human rights everything that
we think is good civil liberties all these things
it's built on property and so finally we have
a property that's independent of the state
cannot be inflated cannot be manipulated can
it be corrupted and that simple opt-out option
forces governments to deal
with this more honestly so
but we live in a society whereby this is a very
libertarian mindset and it's one that i share
and the idea that we should have a small
government if one if any at all um is a very
niche idea particularly in 2022 um so if that
if property is just the sole purpose how did we
get to a point where the government really is in
every aspect of our lives even to the point where
we will protect you take this medicine because we
know that this is better for you how did we get to
a point where the government is in every aspect of
our lives central banking and fiat currency right
a government effectively by having a central bank
implemented inside of a country the government
effectively has a mechanism of unlimited
revenue and you could also say a mechanism
of limited liability so they a government can
go and spend and borrow as much as it likes
misallocate as much capital as it wants run huge
deficits losses right and an economic deficit or
loss that means you're not you're spending
resources that are not satisfying humans
you're wasting resources that's what it means but
when a government can just print new money to pay
for this paper over this bad decision making
this capital misallocation and then externalize
the cost of all that money printing onto the
productive society they're just confiscating
wealth from productive people that are running
profitable businesses creating valuable goods
and services in the world and then channeling
it into the government misallocation of capital
so it's a business that can never lose right
it's heads i win tells you lose from the
state's perspective they can make bad decisions
screw it all up oh well just print more money
i'll confiscate wealth from everyone
that was successful in the marketplace
and then reallocate capital further so fiat
currency has led to the overgrowth of the
state it's led to an overemphasis i argue on
politics people have such a deep connection
to their personal political identity and their
collective political identity they really think
that's the most important thing in the world right
are you liberal are you conservative are you ready
i think these days i find that very important
know what somebody is just in case i think it's
all premised on the viability of property because
in this hypothetical world where you can't hurt me
and you can't steal my stuff this would be this
just a hypothetical world that's not even possible
it's an ideal but in a world where you can't
hurt me you can't steal my stuff why would we
ever argue about political opinions why would
we ever try to put ourselves under one roof if
we don't get along we don't see eye to eye about
whatever issue it is whatever social issue it is
we would just go our separate ways so just so i
can understand you're essentially saying because
you we have a central banking system those at the
top can print more money which ultimately gives
them more power which introduces that monopoly
on property rights and by and being able to have
that authority to confiscate and to threaten
with violence you know if you don't do as i say
am i am i understanding or am i missing it
somewhat like that so again if we're looking
at money as title to human time we could also
label the central bank as an institution of
systemized time theft so they're printing
money right doling it out arbitrarily to a
politically advantaged or connected few at the
expense of everyone else so at the heart of the
quote unquote free market capitalist economy
that we say we have in the united states we
have an anti-capitalist organization that steals
from everyone that's productive and successful
and allocates the stolen proceeds
to those who are unsuccessful
and we end up with things like zombie companies we
end up with just all the political nonsense we see
today like these people have just lost their mind
you see it in their character you see it in their
their duplicity right they're saying one
thing doing another so although money is
like purely a technological it's a kind of a
social technology i think the implications of
corrupting money actually have like they
create a spiritual pathology on the world
that we we end up in this world where we think
we need to impose our opinions on other people
which is anti-libertarian anti-freedom wealth
destructive right so all this is anti-economic
everything that we've figured out to construct
western civilization the concept of fiat meaning
do this because i said so or i will
hurt you that's what fiat means
same thing you use with your kids right clean
up your room or you're going to get a spanking
that's fiat that does not work in the sphere of
adult relations in my opinion i think it's net
value destructive net capital destructive i think
it's corrosive to our character and our behavior
and i think that is where we're at today we're
sick we're very sick and without something like
bitcoin i would be very pessimistic about the
world i felt that pessimism but also that optimism
during 2021 with the lockdowns and i felt you
know at least just on a surface level i sort of
thought well you know they can take away your
job they can take away um your rights to your
body they can take away your right of your freedom
of movement but they can't confiscate your money
um but you tweeted something which i thought was
really um entertaining and i actually thought it
was a joke when you first tweeted it um it
was somebody talking about their pronouns
um and trying to tell their child that it's
it's it's he him not she her and i think i
believe this was a biological woman um and you
said that this is fiat induced psychosis now
a lot of people refer to things like let's just
say like a blue tick on twitter as oh that's fiat
i don't want that so that's sort of what i thought
you were saying but you actually mean it this woke
culture this new wave of um so-called progressive
liberalism is fiat induced so can you go into more
detail on how can you go into more detail on how
this wave of work culture is fiat induced yeah
this is uh admittedly i'm kind of like at the edge
of my own understanding about a lot of this but uh
you know one of the things peterson highlighted
years ago was he was not going to give in to
compelled speech there were laws being passed
in canada that said you must call this person
whatever gender they select for themselves and
through his studies of history he knew once you
started to violate the freedom of speech you would
now be on a slippery slope toward totalitarianism
and so i think there's something about again fiat
existing in the world and it's not just currency
people always especially in bitcoin think
it's just the money but legislation by fiat
right um would you mean legislation by fiat
the english common law tradition was originally
there we would observe how people behaved over
many long periods of time how things had been
resolved traditionally and that discovery process
would be implemented as law it wouldn't be one
guy sitting down writing a law saying this is
law it was an observational discovery process
rather than a process of dictate which is
legislation by fiat do again do this or i'll hurt
you so and the you know like ancient romans didn't
even have a concept of that they actually thought
all law was basically natural law and the job of
the rulers was to discover this and and codify it
not to sit there and write laws and tell
people what to do so again we're sick
like we think this is how we have to do things
we need to coerce people into good behavior
and when you have that perspective in
mind it you end up creating this fight
where everyone wants to get on the side of the
coercive apparatus to try and tell other people
what to do according to their worldview so
everyone's trying to impose their opinions
on others and i think that whole this whole
idea of pronouns right i'm a flag i'm a chair
like it gets absolutely crazy and then if you
don't remember my pronoun and use my pronoun
then i'm gonna coerce you i'm gonna shame you i'm
gonna cancel you like this is asinine that's all
anti-free speech right if you ask me to call you
the pronoun and you're my friend and you're nice
about it maybe we can mutually agree and i'll
agree to do that sure but to try and codify this
like actually bringing to bear legal compulsion
on people that do not speak the pronoun that you
wish to be called i mean this is like an adult
playing imaginary effectively like i want to be
whatever pronoun i've selected and if you
don't call me that thing i'm going to hurt
you so they're like trying to impose opinion
or impose imaginary play in the adult world
so i think this is all contributing to that
psychotic behavior um and it sort of feeds back
onto itself too where it's like if you do give
in to that coercion then all of a sudden like you
know you've been taken advantage of in a certain
way so you feel like you have to play that game
um and it's just very psychologically spiritually
cancerous in my opinion and i think we need to be
rid of all of it we just need freedom like mutual
consensual exchange across the board we need to
absolutely put that at the highest echelon of
our value hierarchy and just like respect and
acknowledge that even in a purely economic
sense that's the only way you create value
like a mutual this is called the inequality
of exchange in economics two people only trade
when you and i would only execute a trade if
you think what i have is more valuable to you
and i think the same thing in reverse i think
whatever you have is more valuable to me than what
i'm giving up that's the only time we trade so
when we both leave that trade we've both produced
a psychological profit we're both better off i got
more value than i gave up you got more value than
you gave up we we increase the aggregate value or
at least the perception of value in the world only
if it's mutual on both sides if it's not mutual
then it's destructive right someone's leaving
that exchange hurt basically and so this idea of
compulsion coercion imposition i think it just
needs to be wiped from human affairs completely
the thing the thing with that is that it becomes
inherently political because where there's people
there's politics right and the i think freedom is
just a political standpoint if you if you you
know take the four-point spectrum whether it's
um you know authoritarianism liberalism
whether it's left right you know whatever it is
so a lot of people say that bitcoin isn't
political um and i understand that you know
the technology isn't political but what
you're saying to me and i entirely agree
is inherently political it's a libertarianism
what's your definition of politics
my definition of politics would be i mean well
it's a hard question um i think where there's
people where there's people that are obsessed with
it they can't define it that's a good one where
there's people there's politics right i again it
depends on the definition here's two definitions
that i've heard that i think makes sense
one is something like the marketplace
is the sphere of distributed cognition so this
is where people are trading with one another
we can all all the information basically in
the marketplace is contained in the price
so we're engaging like our individual cognitive
computational system is plugged into the market
which is like the minds of everyone else
so it's a distributed computing system
i've heard politics defined as the ethics
of that system right so there's a cognitive
element which is the distributed cognition of
the market well we also need distributed ethics
put right on top of that that definition
of politics i can work with right sure we
need some ethical considerations we need
to hash that out we need to talk about it
the other definition of politics which i think is
much more apt to modern reality is this idea of
imposing your opinion yes right we vote world or
nationwide 51 of the people decide they want this
thing then the law is written by fiat and imposed
on the other 49 percent basically that's coercion
that i think is nonsense it's like just just give
people the ability to opt out exit say no then you
are honoring their sovereignty you're honoring
individual decision making and that leads to
human flourishing in my opinion value creation
capital accumulation satisfaction of human wants
so depending on how we define a politics uh i
would agree with you wherever there are people
there are politics in the sense there are ethics
to this system of distributed cognition we have
to engage in to be smart successful creating
wealth uh advancing civilization frankly but
this other idea of politics where i need to shove
my opinion down other people's throat because of i
don't know where people get it honestly i can't
even i've never wanted in my life ever to like
impose my opinion or control someone like that
i just don't i don't know where that comes from
your biggest problem then as a freedom maximalist
and i feel your maximalist kind of says it all
really is doesn't it is is the imposing
right so sort of mandating something no
coercion no compulsion no violence okay so this is
interesting el salvador makes bitcoin legal tender
um and that's all very exciting um but some issues
that i've heard people have and this is something
which is hushed away and we're sort of not allowed
to talk about is the fact that yeah so you so you
have to use it well you could use dollars as well
or not you can use dollars as well i don't know
okay but it has to be accepted because it's
legal tender so if you go to mcdonald's and
you want to buy happy meal whatever it is
you have to accept it a private business
has to accept it i disagree with that you don't
you disagree with i disagree with legal tender law
completely because it is coercion it is compulsion
even though it serves the adoption of bitcoin i
still don't agree with it why don't you think
people talk about that i don't know i didn't
know people don't talk about that i'll talk about
it i don't support it that's interesting um you
have this mindset as well that bitcoin fixes this
and i really want to get into that more um because
it's sort of a cliche that we hear online quite a
lot um particularly about war you have this theory
about war um and what is your theory about war
how does bitcoin prevent war yeah let me answer
i would like to define freedom maximalism actually
um and then i'll answer that question so typically
maximalism means you're going to maximize a
metric at all other costs right so if you were
a what's that dangerous they always talk about the
hypothetical dangerous artificial intelligence if
it was a staple maker or maybe it's a paper clip
maker right that it would just maximize paper clip
production at the cost of everything else in the
world before you know it would all be drowning
in paper clips right so maximalism's typically
used as a derogatory term and i believe bitcoin
maximalism was originally a derogatory term from
vitalik but i want to speak i think freedom is
specifically unique um and i've had it out with
actually bellagi on my show about this he's like
you can't beat maximalism you want to talk about
more optimalism so you want to maximize a certain
metric within some limiting principle right so
you're not drowning in paper clips so to speak
freedom maximalism in my view though is i want
everyone to maximize their freedom in terms of
freedom from coercion freedom to do things so
this would be actually as we accumulate more
capital we're basically giving ourselves more
options right we can do things that we couldn't
do without that capital um you said you flew
here from dubai right that was not an option 200
300 years ago right just didn't exist because we
didn't innovate that so i think freedom maximism
is maximize freedom within the limiting
principle of the private property of others yeah
so it is self-optimizing because property
itself is an expression of freedom it's the
fruit of your past freedom so i think the
ideal world is everyone maximizing their
own freedom within the limiting principle or
within the boundaries of the private property
which is the freedom of others so i think it's
a self-optimalizing to use the bellagi term
ideal so when i say freedom maximalism that's
what i mean like just on that point then why
would you why'd you regard yourself as a freedom
maximalist rather than a bitcoin maximalist
because i think bitcoin mac i clearly support
bitcoin heavily but this idea i see it in the
bitcoin community that they become toxic they want
to attack people for their portfolio construction
they want to moralize people for their anything
communications assets they hold i just don't
believe in that i don't want to be a part of
that culture i'm not going to go shame people
for what they buy buy whatever you want i'll
see you in the marketplace my money will out
compete yours or so i believe maybe you're right
maybe you'll out compete me i have no idea and to
try and attack people it just feels very high
school um and i think it's also decremental
to experimentation like let people experiment
all these [ __ ] coins like i consider them to
be mostly test net for bitcoin but that doesn't
mean i'm gonna like dogmatically attack people
and write these long treatises about why ethereum
sucks and like more power to you if you want to do
that that's fine but i personally want to identify
with the deeper principle you know bitcoin's the
greatest implementation i think we've ever
had of life liberty property which is freedom
but i don't want to dogmatically associate myself
with a culture that i just don't identify with
so in terms of bitcoin fixing it then talk to me
about war how does bitcoin essentially prevent
war because i believe that that's what you say
right yeah and i want to be clear about this
oftentimes when you talk about these big topics
people just think in binaries it's like there's
either war or there's no war right it's like not
necessarily in my opinion everything in reality
exists on a continuum so and the the premise
behind this thinking is you know this is the old
charlie munger quote show me the incentive i'll
show you the outcome so we have these institutions
called states they're monopolist on violence
they're charged with preserving the property
rights of their citizens right keeping the peace
so people can trade and increase wealth but they
tend to bump up against other states all right and
people being the territorial species that we are
and the state being a business i think this is
very important to you that all human organizations
are businesses so they're all growth oriented
they're all trying to grow all trying to expand
revenue trying to become more profitable this
includes government this includes your church this
includes every organization or club you've ever
been a part of like it has to have more economic
inflows and outflows otherwise it doesn't exist
right this is darwinian in a way so throughout
history you know we had the issue where we needed
to and i'm just going to say we needed to i'm not
100 sure we needed the state so much as it's been
imposed upon us but we'll just say we needed this
security outfit to preserve property to have
trade basically to have economies well when those
economic enclaves bump into each other and they're
they're both trying to grow right they're both
trying to expand their territorial footprint what
happens conflict develops typically over resources
also over land it gets painted over with a lot of
moral [ __ ] like oh we're capitalists and you're
communists and we need to bang our belief systems
together uh this is a point i deeply disagree with
peterson on he thinks it's not economic he thinks
we go to war over our belief systems on principle
completely disagree with that because war
is the most anti-economic thing you can do
if you can't pay for it then you can't do
it then you're going to lose basically so
that's been the norm of human history um but when
you get into a world again where you have this in
this property right independent of the state
bitcoin being secured by the mining network
you can no longer fund warfare through inflation
this is really important because the atrocities in
world war 1 and world war ii of the 20th century
the scale and scope and severity of war was unlike
anything we had ever seen because of the central
bank historically governments or these states
would bump into each other they go to war
war is the most expensive thing you can do
they could only fund that warfare from their
own balance sheet from their own war chest
so typically two states go to war someone gets
in financial straits they cut a deal they sign
a treaty there's an armistice whatever well when
you install a central bank all of a sudden that
balance sheet or war chest that they were confined
to their own monetary reserve is now expanded to
the entire savings of civilization because they
can print money to keep paying for for the war
effort until they hyperinflate the currency and
collapse they confiscate all the wealth from the
entire country versus just the state so again this
led to the overgrowth of the state and therefore
the overgrowth of warfare basically so by virtue
of bitcoin existing as an option to opt out of
that inflationary environment that inflationary
means of funding large-scale warfare states now
have to go back to the original means of funding
war which is explicit taxes like i'm sending you
a bill or borrowing this is much more visible
and visceral for people i think the numbers
the u.s war on terror was something like 80 000
for us household wow right but it was all printed
so if you showed up at someone's
household with a bill for 80 000
like hey we're blowing up some
people on the other side of the world
to preserve some oil interest for me and
my buddies i need you to pay this bill
that's why people are going to put up a lot more
resistance right when they're when it's you can
see it versus just printing money and no one
understands it and everyone just feels the pain
and then when prices increase right the actual tax
is being inflicted what do government bureaucrats
say oh it's the greedy capitalist it's the greedy
gas stations why gas prices are up it's the greedy
food manufacturers why why the cost of food is
increasing they'll say anything but debasing
the currency so they can obfuscate this behind
people's ignorance of money and i think over time
basically bitcoin just first of all through
what we're doing just talking about this
this decentralized media and educational effort
i think people are waking up to the realities
of monetary inflation as they're feeling the
pain right like something's not right here
even if people don't understand cognitively what's
going on people in their procedural body knowing
they feel something's really wrong and so i
think states are just going to keep pushing
and this creates a pressure on people to learn
more and find alternative means of saving and
preserving their wealth being independent of the
state that creates capital inflows into bitcoin
and so as bitcoin continues to grow these lessons
spread and now when a country wants to go to war
they're going to have to go tax and borrow
because people because capital if you try to
inflate the currency to pay for that war capital
will leave your country so it's i see bitcoin as a
disincentive to warfare in the long
run and the final piece of that is
bitcoin custodied properly is really hard to
steal so if you ever had a central bank say on a
bitcoin standard when nazi germany invaded poland
they they when the war the invasion of poland
they go straight to their central bank seize all
their gold right they just had a very expensive
war effort to do that they need to go recoup
their costs well rerun that on a bitcoin standard
it's like you would invade poland go straight to
their central bank and there'd be nothing there
presumably you'd the central bank would have
custody did it in multi-sig or whatever and
there'd be no carrot right there's no carrot to
warfare at that point so you're reducing the size
of the carrot to warfare and you're reducing the
ability of states to fund warfare via inflation
so this is like a massive tectonic incentive
shift away from warfare in the long run
so as you speak i have a million questions that
are just firing so just bear with me here okay
so the first point was that i do
agree with peterson and that i think
a lot of war is very philosophical and emotional
um the last uh war between israel and gaza i was
actually sitting in a bomb shelter in israel
when max kaiser tweeted bitcoin fixes this
um and so i do take the stance that i think that
somehow you know religious wars would continue
regardless of a bitcoin standard however when you
say at the end of the day war still costs money
and if the average american you know has to lay
down 80 000 dollars i don't think they're going
to be supporting the war in afghanistan even if
it was philosophical religious spiritual emotional
um so that's interesting yeah you just look at the
cost to benefit of violence right this could be
local violence even a guy breaking into
your house right it's a very risky endeavor
it's gonna break in your house doesn't know who's
there are you armed what's gonna happen he's only
gonna engage in that risky enterprise if there's
some carrot right there's i'm going to steal
the gold there's still the diamonds but in this
vision of a bitcoin eyes world where things are
stored in multi-sig it's really hard to steal
really expensive if not impossible to steal
that carrot goes away so it's like
people just being rational i'm not seeing
this in people i was like what do you mean it'll
never stop violence it'll never stop coercion i'm
not saying it stops it i'm just saying you've
massively shifted the incentives away from it
right that guy that was thinking about
breaking into your house because he had a
whatever percentage roi expectation
that expectation has been crushed
and now he's better off probably going to
get a job over here and just trading and
cooperating with people to produce an roi for
himself so that's what i'm saying it's like we
we're not purely rational economic actors i
agree with that i know people fight over all
types of passionate things like i get that but the
systemization of conflict at scale tends to be a
rational affair you're going to do it if there's
something to be gained and bitcoin makes it such
that there is less to be gained from conflict
than there is from cooperation and you said that
the the war is paid for via inflation right
which therefore requires money to be printed
before the war um so this is interesting yeah
so what's interesting right now is we've had um
the pandemic trying to think of ways to say
that without red flags and stuff like that
um yeah we've had one of them yeah pandemic
um and a lot of money was printed and now
we are supposedly on on the verge
of world war three with inflation
skyrocketing i don't really think we are but you
know with inflation skyrocketing and everything so
do you think there's it's almost is war
planned like do they print the money
ready to start inflation ready to ready
to pay for war is war planned yes i am so
lost actually when i try to think behind the eyes
of statist and statism i'm not sure if they are
very evil villain level coordinated
you know you hear all about um
these certain families that have run the world
for 500 years and it's all planned it's been
orchestrated yeah the trilateral commission and
the bilderberg group all i don't know i don't know
frankly i deviate between that and have you seen
the netflix movie don't look up oh my god it was
awful i thought i was gonna throw up but i think
government i equally think government might yes
also just be like that and it's the
thinking on the thinking there is
you become so frivolous and worthless and
incompetent when you can just press money
and like confiscate wealth it's like you have no
ins there's no check there's no reconciliation to
reality that's sharpening you and hardening you
and and conditioning you to you have no skin in
the game frankly you just don't feel cost or
pain so you just grow um there's an atrophy
an atrophy of of the brain that occurs in that
sphere and clearly i'm speaking generally here
i know there's politicians that are maybe
fighting for life liberty property and all that
it's not black or white but in general i think
when you can just confiscate money at will
it's you have every incentive let's say
this way it's much easier to spend other
people's money than your own correct that's my
problem essentially you just be frivolous right
well social democracy is the same
anywhere there's taxation or inflation
it's not their money it's being confiscated yeah
it's incredible it's all theft so if you derive
your revenues via theft do you think it's entirely
theft 100. 100 so did you did you get to negotiate
your tax bill last year did you have the power
to say no absolutely not i remember i paid it
and i was very upset about it can you opt out
can you exit the jurisdiction now some you can
some you could actually be like i don't
like the rate here i'm going somewhere else
um in the u.s i think two million dollars you have
a two million dollar net worth which is a lot of
money but it's not an incredible amount of money
you can't even opt out you try to say i don't want
to be in the us anymore i'm gonna leave you get
hit with an exit tax so you can't say no what's
the exit tax how much is that i don't know okay
but they tax part of your net worth when you say
imagine going to a car dealership and you're gonna
buy a car and you can't come to terms you're like
i'm gonna leave your car dealership now and they
say actually you're gonna pay me that's literally
like um it's literally a [ __ ] coin there are
so many projects out there that say if you sell
we'll tax you to sell and then they make it sound
like a good thing because it's just like nah it's
so we can make people hold fiat's the ultimate
[ __ ] coin literally by definition right one
node database the federal reserve it's
an sql database maintained on premise
governed by seven guys i guess and they uh
there's no it's all proof of stake so proof of
stake add as many zeros as they want and you get
no say-so how many dollars are there who gets to
decide what are their criteria for deciding who's
profiting who's who's collecting the senior ridge
on the us dollar none of this is talked about no
this is voted upon there's no democratic process
it's the most twisted game in the world it's the
biggest pyramid scheme in human history so what
would your ideal world look like don't just say a
bitcoin standard because what does that mean right
like do you believe there's okay there should
be some level of democracy should we have people
should we vote on every issue so we have direct
democracy um what is your ideal world look like
i think first of all the free market
itself is an actual economic democracy
the idea of democracy that we have
today representative democracy
again based on the reality that property can be
violated right that's what's funding the mechanism
and that's also what's being used to impose
the decisions that come out of it if the 51
vote for a thing they now need to impose on the 49
percent that's based on the viability of property
if property weren't violated weren't viable rather
they would just split when there's a disagreement
so i think the distant long run and this is very
much influenced by the book i talk about a lot the
sovereign individual is that i think software you
know andreessen said software's eating the world
10 or 15 years ago proved to be exceptionally
prescient i think software is also eating the
state so i think we move from a world over time
i don't know how long this is going to take
when i say this people think i'm
crazy they're like it'll never happen
we have 200 some odd countries
today i think we have 20 000
after some period of time i don't know hundreds
of years thousands of years i'm not sure but it
our socio-economic realities come to reflect our
technological realities so the nation state was
a large governance structure for industrial scale
technologies we now are most most of our attention
is flowing through digital technologies
the microprocessor right the era of mass
customization and communication and all this i
think our sovereignty structures our socioeconomic
systems will come to reflect that so much more
decentralization much more small scale governance
much more grassroots everything right much
more options many more options for people
so that's the trajectory i don't know how long it
takes so that was gonna be my next question um i
did an interview with mark moss and he sort
of talks about you know peak centralization
at 2025 and how we're living through the
one of the most unprecedented eras whereby
you know we're seeing peak centralization
from a financial standpoint technological
just it's just everything um and it
feels like it's it's reaching its peak
um i think covid was was really part of that um
inflation highest in 40 years so do you think
the net because you know we have the social credit
system coming in cbdc's which we can get into
um but do you think we're actually going to get to
that sort of authoritarian level do you think it's
going to get much worse or do you think a bitcoin
standard are not a syrian bitcoin standard yet but
do you think bitcoin or this idea of freedom of
decentralization is going to come in and solve
the issue of authoritarianism that we're seeing
i think it's going to play out unevenly around
the world you know one one thing i really liked
with my conversation from bellagio is he has this
thesis of centralized east decentralized west okay
um makes a lot of sense actually china's already
super centralized they've got this
thing rolled out they have the people
effectively conditioned where almost like
they've taken that stockholm syndrome of statism
to like across multiple generations so
people it's sad really one of the things i've
one of the ways i've come to look at
the world is that we are programmable
those of us that understand that we'll strive to
program ourselves right we'll choose the things
we eat the people we spend our time with the
books we read our circumstances the businesses
we run our lifestyle those that don't understand
that though can be preyed upon by those that do
and that seems to be that fiat
slash totalitarian impulse right um
so that i don't know you know i think there's
gonna be pockets of different things happening
around the world but again the long run is the
more you oppress people the more you drive talent
and capital away from that oppression smart money
and smart people will go to where they are treated
best and in the 21st century via the internet via
bitcoin via telecommunications via encryption uh
capital and interpersonal
mobility is higher than ever
so i just don't think this this control mechanism
is going to be as effective in the 21st century
as it was historically all that said there's also
the dystopian view which is what china is doing
today right so if you can get that rolled out on
top of people without them understanding if we can
roll out cbdc's in this country and you know they
always wrap it in some moral camouflage or some
ubi like incentive you know sign up for
your wallet and get your free money and
here's your your bug provider so you don't
need steak anymore you just eat the bugs
yeah let's go into that um so you mentioned um
that people are programmable um and then you said
once you know that you can then choose the foods
you eat so this is fascinating i want to go into
the food topic actually um because this is
something i've recently stumbled across um
i'm obviously british and in the uk the food's all
right there a lot of the way the food is processed
in the us is actually illegal um in the eu and you
can tell when i've traveled in europe it's much
better oh well i can tell i was here for three
months at the end of um 2021 and i like my body
blew up like i literally put on so much weight i
was still hungry i wasn't overeating i put on so
much weight um and now i've hired a nutritionist
and now i'm back in the us and i'm fine
um but i didn't realize what goes on with the food
here i had no idea this is another interesting
aspect of the bitcoin rabbit hole because you
start you know you start seeing through the fiat
illusion and again not just money not just law
it's also like i would argue food and culture
um the food thing's interesting the
biggest one that i'm on now is seed oils
yep everyone's on seed oils they're in everything
with a label even the healthy snack crackers or
almond butter bar or whatever healthy food you
think you're eating it probably has seed oil in it
so and what's wrong with seed oils i'm not well
versed enough to sit here and lay out a scientific
explanation of what's wrong but i can relate
my personal experience so when i was in my 20s
i used to feel very robust and
healthy i think as most of us do
as i got to 30 i started to have issues and
whatnot um i'm now 36 today i cut out seed oils
probably eight to 12 months ago pretty
seriously i mean there were there were
i was already experimenting with carnivore a
couple of years prior to that so i'd kind of
like accidentally cut out seed oils before i
really knew about them um i guess the gist of
what's wrong with them is when you cook or
consume these oils that are not naturally
occurring or either compressing a lot of oil or
taking a lot of seed to make a little bit of oil
it just our body doesn't deal with it well it
causes negative things there's a lot of twitter
accounts you can go follow on research and all
that to get more information for me personally
i went from barely one of
the main things i noticed
i could barely stand 15 minutes of sunlight like
direct sunlight like i would start to get just
just feel burnt right i needed to get out of the
sun i've been living in hawaii the past 14 months
when i got real serious on this really just eating
beef salt fruit raw milk and we cook everything at
home like there's no seed oils don't eat out don't
mess around at all i started being able to go into
the sun for just hours and hours and hours and
i wouldn't really get burned i'd go surf like
all day with sun cream on or no something no no
really yeah and then i've always had uh sort of
dry skin like on my arms and face so i've always
had to put moisturizer on stop needing to do that
um i've had different kinds of inflammation like
in my joints around my nose things like this all
that started to go away um gut inflammation
not feeling well like all that went away
um so it's been been quite transformative for
me and it it really is that simple like i've
tried i tried a lot of interventions before
i got into this diet thing um but just eating
the foods that we've been eating for millions
of years turns out to be pretty good for you
yeah we've been uh eating meat as
well right we're adapted to it so
the diet i mean i could so the diet i
was having was a frozen berry raw milk
smoothie in the morning and then i was when you
say raw milk what do you mean like cow's milk
straight from the cow oh straight from the cave
yeah we had a provider in kauai which you can't i
don't think it's legal to drink raw milk so we had
a provider in hawaii you know we go and pick it up
uh once a week it's delicious but is the and how's
the cow fed and raised uh they are just organic
i i don't know if they eat grass or grain but
they're just free-range cows in hawaii so um
so make the smoothie and then lunch dinner was
basically just beef and salt beef and salt i would
also mix in some sauerkraut and other fermented
foods occasionally all that did well for me but
it was it's good it improved a lot of things that
were going wrong in my 30s so i highly recommend
studying about seed oils studying about the
carnivore diet um and it's not it's not just
carnivore because carnivore is like just beef
and salt right again having fruit and whatnot
added to this uh they call it the abundance diet
there's a great actually a friend of mine paul
he's at carnivoremd on instagram okay he's a
doctor he talks about all this uh there's like a
spectrum right where meat and organs were the most
desired foods then fruit and vegetables and grains
legumes all of this so there's a whole spectrum
and if you just focus on eating the healthy
end of the spectrum you tend to do better and
it's not one size fits all we're all adapted
to different things we have different ancestral
pathways so you have to do some experimentation
and figure out what works for you but it changes
everything in life once you get a hold of it yeah
it's interesting um because there is this push in
society again in the media there's more propaganda
when it comes to your diet and you mentioned um
eating bugs instead of meat and there's that film
i think it's called snow sniper or something snow
peas okay um let's delve into this so why is that
propaganda right now staring people away from
meat and i think i even saw maybe an article on
bloomberg or one of them which was um saying you
know bugs are actually better for you than meat i
the one that really scared me as i saw a quote
from klaus schwab if i'm saying his name correctly
do you know what who cares if you're not saying
you're crazy they're real life dr evil yeah real
life james bond villain yeah basically saying
that we need to abolish this is the head of the
world economic forum as i understand it we need to
abolish private property and stop eating meat like
this is one little quote of his i'm not saying
it exactly but paraphrasing the fact that someone
that's the head of the world economic forum can
blatantly say we need to abolish private property
when an economy is not possible you cannot have
an economy without property property is your
relation to the fruit of your labor that you
then trade with others to produce the economy
when you have the head of the world economic
forum saying we need no more property that's
not what he's saying he's saying property for me
not for thee right question that question that
property is the basis of civilization if
there's an individual telling you we need
to abolish private property it's equivalent
to saying we need to abolish civilization
read iron rand read read mises like this is
very cut and dry and then so that's scary and
disgusting enough but then they're saying
okay and we also need to stop eating meat
meat is the most desirous food and we've
literally been eating it for millions of years
who is this guy that's been around for
80 something years to come on the scene
or his organization whatever and tell us what
we should eat i mean it's one of the most
scary uh specters of freedom violation
i can imagine to try and dictate by
fiat what you eat it's it's insane so i
just really want to understand the fiat
place here it's because it's the legislation
you eat whatever you want
who can tell you what to eat
i agree with you but it's the fear right because
you say dictate by fiat yes well i guess maybe i'm
double emphasizing it in that case but to dictate
what someone eats to eat this eat what i tell you
or i will hurt you that's what fiat means
do this whatever it is eat this thing
because i said so or i will hurt you they don't
need to say all that right there can just be a
veiled thread of force behind it right just like
there there are laws you know do this or else
you break the law you suffer the consequences
when that starts to be applied to your dietary
choice i mean you are what you eat right this is
a very concerning attack on freedom and i think
i think you've just got to stand up for it and
do not comply frankly like over my dead body will
you ever tell me what to eat i will eat whatever i
want how far would you go all the way all the way
i'd like to get your just on that then i'd
like to get your opinion um on djokovic um
so um the tennis player he didn't go to australia
to play the big game because he wasn't he hadn't
had the the medicine right um and i was really
impressed by that actually um because a lot of
people especially you know on twitter and you have
all these these big alpha accounts or whatever and
sort of talk about freedom and all this stuff
um but when it came down to it he was willing to
sacrifice his career hmm good for him right yeah
so how far would you go literally over your dead
body freedom maximalism like i will stand for it
to my death and i hope that if that comes to pass
that i am at least a shining example for others
i think it's important um that's what we need
more of a society i think that's actually the
problem a lot of people um aren't don't have
the courage don't have the bravery and don't have
the strength um i think that's sort of why we see
i believe the emasculation of men from the media
um and things like that um so in your opinion
honestly do you see there being do you see
that there's an agenda being pushed here
well certainly when you're talking about the
abolition of private property i mean i don't
know how you could call that anything but an
agenda because we have private property to
some extent in the world um again thank god for
bitcoin the ultimate form of private property
if you want to abolish that then that is
i mean that is by definition an agenda right it's
changing a thing that exists so i don't know again
back to the government conversation like how
coordinated and intelligent is this versus just
people that have just lost their mind right
if you look if you spend too much time in the
ivy ivory tower you just lose touch with the
real world so maybe they think they're just
the bill gates or whoever at that level we
don't need these things anymore i have this
new solution but this is very important too in
paradise loss uh milton has this line he says
evil is the knowledge which believes itself
complete so when someone has a model of the
world a mental model of the world that
they think is the final answer right
and they're trying to impose that onto others
that is evil right what is good is what is what
people discover what people naturally move towards
through a free market discovery process right i
have wants i have felt uneasiness as mises says i
go into the world i engage in voluntary exchange
with others to try and solve that usually solving
a problem i have is also a problem other people
have so i can be an entrepreneur and sell that
solution into the marketplace others are doing
the same we all cooperate we increase wealth to
increase human satisfaction we create civilization
if instead i try to take that mental model and
impose it on people i'm engaging in evil so
these i and the the pernicious thing about evil
too is that i i am i tend to believe that someone
like that may actually think they're doing good
right he may actually think he's saving the world
in his heart of hearts i don't know but i could
just speculate to think that maybe claudia was
like no we have to do this to save the world we're
going to destroy the world if we don't do this
he may actually think he is a good man doing the
right thing and he's being righteous in his action
but that's dangerous right that's
deceptive he's being misled by his own
idea of imposing a mental model on others rather
than letting people discover what's best for them
so it's all to do with that relationship between
the people the government and private property
and though the way bitcoin comes into it is
because obviously it's decentralized right
you truly own that so if we look at a bitcoin
standard and a world where you know bitcoin's
been adopted does that include let's say the deed
to your house being on the bitcoin network as an
nft or something like that i don't know how you
know there's a lot of experiments being done where
you can execute property transactions and higher
protocols on the bitcoin network that would be
independent of state authorization but when it
comes to again property being the relationship
between people and their stuff so physical
people in relation with their physical stuff
and the physical world you're gonna need
physical security to satisfy that i don't think
i think it's gonna be a much smaller business
overall basically like it's a business that's
blown itself up on fiat i say i mean expanded
itself excessively on fiat but when property
can be secured more cheaply and when there's less
incentive to violence like we talked about earlier
the need for physical security should be reduced
as well so the physical security business model
should shrink as well do you truly think that
we're going to get onto a bitcoin standard i don't
know how you stop it bitcoin is like this vortex
of positive incentives so i think when you see
the game theoretic aspects of it that everyone's
cooperating competing in the marketplace
to try and secure economic value for themselves
we all have an incentive to hold that in a medium
that is most resistant to the opinions of
others right i want to hold my money my uh
economic life force or monetary energy as sailor
might say i want to hold that in something
that no one else's opinions or behaviors or
actions can affect right the most untouchable
asset is the most desirous asset and that's what
bitcoin is can't inflate it can't confiscate it
can't interrupt the network can't turn
it off can't reverse it can't stop it
so how does that not become how how
is bitcoin i can't imagine bitcoin not
having um an incredible amount of demand in a
world where we're freezing the bank accounts
of peaceful protesters where we're freezing the
foreign reserves of russia when they go to war
like this pain that people and
institutions are going to feel
through the security vulnerability of fiat that
it can be shut off canceled c's etc that's going
to push them into and towards this untouchable
asset that's my opinion do you think that the
increasing authoritarianism that we're seeing
you mentioned canada you mentioned um freezing
um you know seizing accounts of russians and so
on do you think that in a perverse way that's kind
of going to be good for bitcoin in terms of waking
people up pain is information literally that's how
organisms adapt right they're dealing with some
situation in their environment that they're not
if it's a giraffe trying to eat the tree and
it's not long enough it's feeling the pain of
not getting the food that it wants and then
over many generations its neck gets longer
or the turtle gets attacked and there's some maybe
gap in its shell that one of its uh predators is
exploiting and then over time the turtle shell
adapts like we we are informed by pain and you
know this in your own life right if you've ever
if you just win and succeed over and over and
over that can lead you astray actually it's those
times where you screw up and you learn a lesson
the hard way that's what reforms you changes your
character that's what working out is right you go
into the gym and you consciously apply physical
adversity to your body to force it to adapt
and working out hurts right you can't have in
you can't put yourself in formation without pain
so all the educational effort that we do i think
it's very important and i'd love to be a part of
it but sort of paradoxically government action is
the greatest billboard for bitcoin in the world
and i'll never we will never be able to speak
louder than that and so yes in my opinion it's a
bit unfortunate but it is fundamental to reality
that people and organisms learn through pain
i think you're i totally agree with you um a
lot of people talk about nfts and all this stuff
being the road to adoption but i think it's
just fun you know um i think it's the pain
where the innovation comes from um so what would
you say right now where are we at right now
because there's obviously a lot of um hostility
from governments particularly in the u.s um
i think it was elizabeth warren that just
refused to be taught about bitcoin and you know
its connection to illicit activity or
being able to enable illicit activity so
where are we at with bitcoin adoption
right now i had a guest on um past few days
mr larry lepard and he said we are at 25 of u.s
population holding bitcoin i didn't know it was
that high i thought we were a sub 10 um i don't
know i don't know and i don't know that you can
even trust the data necessarily i'm not sure how
it's derived i don't i don't spend a lot of time
trying to figure it out either so maybe there's
a way to figure it out accurately i'm not sure
um i'm just looking at the incentives ultimately
like what's happening in the world and what are
people's incentives in the long run and
so it's really hard to predict the future
but i think if you look at economics you
can at least establish a probabilistic
trajectory for things right like you could have
if you understood the internet you probably could
have figured out that traditional media was
[ __ ] 20 years ago right you just understand
the economic model is superior right it's
cheaper distribution zero cost of bandwidth
you know improves margins
for creators things like this
so if you just look at the economic circumstances
within a given technological paradigm i think it
gives you some indication of the direction the
world's going and so very simply with bitcoin
in a world where everyone's printing money
everyone like every central bank is violating
the private property rights of their citizenry
at an unprecedented rate the money that no one can
print right the property that no one can violate
becomes increasingly desired in that world and you
can't reverse the fiat this fiat debt spiral like
you keep you need to print more and more money to
keep the system sustainable so inflation is not
linear right it's it's exponential went from
a 700 billion dollar bill out in 2008 to 20
trillion and 20 20. the next one's probably
going to be in the hundreds of trillions
and before you know it bread and milk are going
to be thousands of dollars and the dollars are not
going to make sense anymore they're not going to
be relevant they're not going to hold their value
you won't even be able to think
in it you know in weimar germany
things got so bad that people would order
all their beers at the beginning of the night
because they would increase the price of beer
three or four times throughout the night one
night at the bar so you'd go to the bar and you'd
order your 10 beers or whatever the beginning of
the night and that was where was this and when
this is weimar germany in the 20s i believe wow
hyperinflation's really really really bad just
spend the next 24 hours count how many times you
use money or think in money or negotiating money
now imagine that money has lost all meaning and
you can't how do you do anything how do you do
anything how long do you think the us dollar has
left i have a public prediction that the us dollar
is hyperinflated into worthlessness by 2035.
i could be wrong i just looked at historical
hyperinflations the timing of them in terms of
percentage of supply increase where again
it gets orders of magnitude worse each time
there tends to be a breaking point hyperinflation
i think is 50 month over month inflation price
inflation is the technical definition for for
hyperinflation and i think we get there by 2035
just based on some proxies from history you made
a tweet recently um which was pretty controversial
um after this conversation is sort of
starting to make a little bit more sense
um sex is was it rapist as sex as fiat is to
bitcoin something like that yeah let's go into
that what did you mean what did you mean by that
tweet yeah i was accused of trivializing rape
um i was also accused of making a category error
and that i should never compare these two things
but the the end of the tweet was mutual consent
matters right and it does right the difference
between sex and rape is consent the difference
between a transaction and theft is consent the
difference between a job and slavery is consent
the power to say no is the root of sovereignty
if you can't if you don't have the power to
say no if someone's physically coercing you
over your attestation to the contrary like stop
no i want to leave no more of this then that's
a non-consensual exchange and you're in the
realm of immorality and evil in my estimation
um it could have been an insensitive
tweet because i know people have been
through things that are horrible and terrible but
hyperinflations are pretty horrible and terrible
and the wars that fiat currency funds
are pretty horrible and terrible
there were 169 million people murdered in
the 20th century by states fiat funded states
i'll say that again and this is from a state
university study university of hawaii study
they call it demicide it's such a
huge tragedy they gave it its own name
169 million people murdered in the
20th century by fiat funded states
i know rape is bad that's pretty bad too
yeah i understand um i enjoyed the comments
and i enjoyed the the whole thing um but but i
understand it's the mutual the lack of mutual
consent um and naturally if you talk about fiat
and um how it funds wars and war equals death then
you have rape and you have death so they're both
good sounds pretty bad and um and i was attacked
and people like be careful you're gonna get
canceled again and i'm like cancel me what does
this fiat cancel [ __ ] cancel me i don't care
i'm sorry the tweet was not sensitive unfollow me
okay i am actually genuinely sorry to anyone that
like took offense to it and feel bad about it
like i'm sorry but i hope if you've listened
to this interview that i'm not trivializing
anything i'm very serious i think this is
the number one problem we face as a species
is this element of coercion compulsion violence
and it's all remedied by putting all of our
emphasis on mutual consent in all human relations
and so you think that a bitcoin standard is
inevitable is that correct i don't believe
in the word word inevitable you know
there's no way to know the future and
anyone that lives by the crystal ball
is bound to eat glass but i just think
i call it an unstoppable vortex of positive
incentives it's probably one of the
best phrases i've found for it you know it's
incentivizing everyone to contribute to the
proliferation and success of its network that's
how it works basically it's ingenious so if we
don't destroy ourselves by fiat first then i think
bitcoin has a very high likelihood of success
robert i want to thank you so much i really
appreciate you breaking down all of those ideas
um i've never actually heard somebody speak
about war and how bitcoin truly fixes this um
i know it's this catchphrase that we
hear in um in the community a lot so i
really appreciate you taking the time to truly
explain how bitcoin fixes all of these problems
thank you so much i really enjoyed the
conversation you asked great questions thank
you so much any final words you'd like to offer
of wisdom i don't know when this is airing but
we're doing a live event on friday night in miami
that's april 8th um it's going to be my air after
maybe maybe friday i'm not sure well um we're
also going to release a recording of that live
event the live events on april 8th we have
a special guest for the what is money show
we're going to record in front of a live studio
audience in miami at the bitcoin 2022 conference
i will release that episode on youtube and podcast
probably two weeks later so it's like end of april
um and i hope and intend for it to be one of
those timeless bitcoin discussions so i hope
you guys will check it out guys don't forget to
follow robert on all socials he has a newsletter
he has a youtube twitter and am i missing anything
else no that's it yeah the freedom analytics is
the sub stack the what is money shows the youtube
and podcast and twitter is at breedlove2020 22
breedlove22 not 2022. that's really tongue twisted
me a lot this year so far yeah i can imagine
robert thank you so much thank you so much guys
thanks so much for watching please don't forget to
hit the subscribe button so you never miss another
fantastic interview we'll see you next week